So Nancy Pelosi, Democratic speaker of the
House, went on CNN. She was interviewed by
Wolf Blitzer. It didn't go very well.
And she's correctly, understandably,
taking some heat for how this all went down.
So let's look at it. I have some thoughts.
Let's get right right into the first clip. First
off, Wolf Blitzer asks, why won't you accept the
Republican proposal for a corona virus relief? And
Nancy Pelosi says it's a bad deal for the people.
As you know, there are Americans who are
beiftallng evicted from their homes. They
can't pay the rent. Many Americans are
waiting in food lines for the first time
in their lives. Can you look them in
the eye, Madam Speaker, and explain
why you don't want to accept the
president's latest stimulus offer?
Well, because thank you very much, Wolf,
and I hope you'll ask the same question
of the Republicans about why they don't really
want to meet the needs of the American people
about let me say to those people, because all of
my colleagues, we represent these people I have
for over 30 years represented my constituents. I
know what their needs are. I listen to them and
their needs are not addressed in the president's
proposal. So when you say to me, why don't you
accept theirs? Why don't they accept ours?
So this is okay so far. But then it starts to
get heated as Wolf Blitzer pushes back and Nancy
Pelosi goes after Wolf and his colleagues. And
this is where it started to not not be so good.
Excuse me for interrupting. Go bankrupt,
Madam Speaker, but they really need the
money right now. And even members of
that. But but even members, of course, question
even members of your own caucus, Madam Speaker,
want to accept this deal. One point a trillion
dollars, Congressman Rowe content Lewenza. Let me
just say, you just quote Prokhanov man, you know.
Well, I assume you admire him. He's a Democrat and
he just said this is a people in need. Can't wait
until February. One point a trillion dollars is
significant and more than twice the Obama stimulus
make a deal. Put the ball in McConnell court.
So what do you say to Roxana when I say to you
is I don't know why you're always an apologist.
And many of your colleagues, apologists for
the Republican position. Roxana. That's nice.
That isn't what we're going to do. And nobody's
waiting till February. I want this very much now.
So now Nancy Pelosi is starting to get agitated
with Wolf Blitzer and he's asking completely fair
questions thus far. The problem here is not Wolf
Blitzer. He's being a journalist. And here, Wolf
Blitzer tries again, not precisely why that is.
Seems like they're concerned. That's
great. So several important right now.
Yesterday, I spoke to Andrew Young,
who says the same thing. It's not everything
you want. You know, there's a lot of care.
Honest to God here, really, I can. I
can't get over it because Andrew Yang,
he's lovely. Yale Alcon Retcon. He's lovely.
They are not negotiating this situation. They
have no idea of the particulars. They have
no idea of what the language is here. I
did come over here to have you. So you're
the apologist for the Obama appeasement.
Got tremendous amount of speakers that. Not just
I'm asking you serious questions because so many
people are just for you and weak right now.
So now Nancy Pelosi starts to get flustered.
And I think that basically everybody's
being sort of unfair in their reactions
here. It is absolutely true that Wolf Blitzer
is doing nothing wrong. He's asking questions.
He's asking reasonable questions, questions we
all deserve answers to, which essentially are
if you want corona virus relief and Trump is
willing to do something on it, why wouldn't you
just take it? And Nancy Pelosi has to explain
that she has do that. That's OK. That's fair.
That's completely reasonable. Yes. Nancy Pelosi is
wrong to go after Wolf and CNN because he's just
asking questions and reasonable ones and attacking
the journalist is a very bad look. But in addition
to that, without defending Nancy Pelosi, she's
dealing with a lunatic and Donald Trump in trying
to get this coronaviruses stimulus done. And that
frustration is clearly coming through here. Now,
her most astute statement there is that neither
Yang nor Ro Karna are negotiating this with Trump,
and it has to be insane to be negotiating this
with Trump. So I sympathize with her for that. But
it's letting the frustration boil over
on. Wolf Blitzer as if he's asking bad
questions is a terrible look. And Wolf
comes back in with more questions.
Let me ask you this. When was the last time you
saw me respond to you? When we signed by the
speaker. When was the last time you
spoke with the president about this?
I don't speak that press being
like this, representative.
Why not call him and say, Mr. President, let's
work out a deal? It's not going to be everything
you want. Not going to be everything I want.
But there are so many Americans right now
who are in desperate need. Let's make a deal.
What makes me amused. If it weren't so sad
is how you all think that you know more about
the suffering of the American people than those
of us who are elected by them to represent them at
that table. It is unfortunate that we do not have
shared values with this White House and that they
have in their bill. Why don't you talk about their
bill? A tax break for the wealthiest families
in the country while they cut out the earned
income tax credit for the poorest families in our
country and the poorest children in our country.
So, again, Nancy Pelosi saying it's Wolf who has
no idea it's not his job to have an idea here,
Wolf, is there is a journalist to ask questions
like if Trump's OK with one point eight trillion,
why won't you take it and
get money to people? That's
fair. And there are reasonable people on
the left asking that exact same question.
And Pelosi could tackle that without
attacking Wolf Blitzer. It's a mistake.
She's making a mistake. I get the frustration
and the frustration grows in this next clip.
It will be read here. Here's what you wrote
in a letter to House Democrats. Madam Speaker,
I ask these questions only as you know, so many
millions of Americans are suffering for, you know,
two people who know nothing about the agreement.
Well, there is no agreement. But what the
suggestions are as if there's some authority on
the subject because he's given equal weight to,
well, to all of the chairman of the
committee who have written this.
But so many of your fellow Democrats in the House,
they want a deal right now. That isn't the problem
solvers. They all want a deal right now. And
here's what they're complaining about, because
you wrote a letter to House Democrats and you said
this. I read a line from the letter you wrote,
The president only wants his name on a check to go
out before Election Day and for the market to go
up. Is that what this is all about? Not allow the
president to take credit if there there's a deal
that will help. I know he has Americans right now.
He's not that important. But let me say this.
With all due respect, with all due respect to,
you know, we've known each other a long time.
You really don't know what you're talking
about. If the plural of anecdote is not data,
yes. There's some people who said this or
that. Overwhelmingly, my caucus wants what is
right for the American people. Overwhelmingly, our
chairman who wrote the bill read their statements.
They all put out their own statements when
they saw what the White House was proposing.
So this was bad. This is very, very bad. I
understand why Pelosi's views is running short.
But this is like when the Trump
people are sent out to defend Trump
and they get frustrated because Trump lies all the
time. And then they have to defend Trump's lies
on media, in media interviews, and they end
up attacking the interviewer when the Trump
defenders do it. It's wrong. And when Nancy
Pelosi does it, it's wrong and it's a bad look.
So this did go horribly wrong, but not because
Pelosi was frustrated. She should have pushed
the frustration onto Trump and Republicans.
And she should have said, listen, Wolf,
you're doing your job and you're asking reasonable
questions, which the American people deserve
answers to understand what's going on. Trump says
he'll sign off on money. So why hasn't it been
been done? Very reasonable. But understand the
impossible position I'm in. Where Trump tells me
no deal via Twitter, via Twitter last week. Trump
says no deal. Stop negotiating. Then he goes to a
rally and says, get people money. The Democrats.
Well, I say I'm for money. The Democrats aren't.
Mitch McConnell says no more deals. Mitch
McConnell has been saying for months we're
not doing any more stimulus. Understand the
bipolar nature of the situation and then I'm
thrown into it. So your questions of me are fair,
but recognize the insanity. But when she goes
off on Wolf, it backfires completely. It makes
her an unsympathetic character. And now she has
to deal with the fallout from this interview.
So Wolf Blitzer did nothing wrong. It's Nancy
Pelosi who is in the wrong understanding, her
frustration with the completely manic bipolar
insanity of trying to negotiate this with a Donald
Trump who says something different every two hours
on Twitter. At a rally, so on and so forth. That's
essentially my my take on the way this went down.